بعد ساعات من وقف الهدنه المعلنه من طرف
واحد من قبل موسكو في اوكرانيا اشتدت
المعارك على محاور كل من باخ موت ودنياسك
شرقي البلاد واستانفات القوات الروسيه
قصفها على كافه القواعد العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في كل المحاور والمدن التابعه
لمقطعه دونياسكو لوجاس معلنه تدمير
مستودعات اسلحه اوكرانيه هناك هذا وكان
الجيش الاوكراني قد اعلن ان قوته الجويه
والصاروخيه استهدفت سته وعشرين موقعا
روسيا خلال 24 ساعه فيما قالت سلطات دنيا
القوات الاوكرانيه استخدمت صاروخ توشكا
اوه في ضرباته وفي ضربات اليوم هذا وتحتدم
المعارك في محور باخم بعد ما سيطرت قواته
الروسيه على مواقع في شماليه المدينه
وشرقها وجنبها مطوقه بلده سوليدار ومدينه
طبعا في خطوه انتقاميه وصفات وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تنفيذ الضربه لمقتل جنودروس في
ضربه صاروخيه في مقياسكا ليله راس السنه
وقالت الدفاع الروسيه انها قصفت مبنى فكره
موتورز شرقي اوكرانيا ما اودى بحياه اكثر
من 600 جندي اوكرانيه بدورها نفات كيا
بالخبر ومقتل هذا العدد معتبره البيان
الروسي دعايه مبال
غ
ردينكا في دونتس نفذت القوات الروسيه
عمليه انتقاميه خلال الاربع ايام ساعه
الماضيه اكتشفت المخابرات الروسيه نقاط
الانتشار المؤقته للقوات الاوكرانيه في
كرامته تضم مئات الجنود قتل منهم اكثر من
600 جندي في هجوم صاروخين روسي مكثف
نمر
مراسل العربيه
سابدا معك عبد الجواد بما اننا نتحدث عن
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه كيف هي اجواء
وصدى هذه العمليه بعد ان نفي الاوكراني
يعني اوكرانيا تقول تم في هذه العمليه من
الاساس
مساء الخير
هي عمليه انتقاميه قامت بها موسكو تردد
فعل
ليلتي رئيس السنه بسقوط 10
اوكرانيه طبعا لو فيك الحقيقه بان الهدنه
كان شيء غريب وشيء طبعا لما يعني لم يصل
الى ما رغبه موسكو وطبعا رفضها كثيرون في
الداخل الروسي باعتبارها لم ت- يعني لم
تصل لاين نتائج باعتبر قامت بيردد فعل
عسكريه على اماكن على الاماكن التي خرجت
منها ضربات اوكرانيه وسقط في خلال ساعات
الهدنه اكثر من 100 و20 جندي اوكرانيا لكن
طبعا ما حدث اليوم هو يعني عنوان كل
الحوارات ان كانت في الاخبار وان كانت في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعيه بان موسكو عادت
لضربتها القويه وضربتها الصاروخيه على
النقاط التحتيه همم العسكريا الجانب
الاوكراني والاعداد طبعا ونلاحظ ان بي ان
بيان وزاره الدفاع اليوم ليتحدث لاول مره
منذ فتره طويله عن اسقاط اربعه يعني
طائرات حربيه اربع مقاتلات من طراسه من
غيره يعني ومن غيره لذلك طبعا هذا البيان
اليوم يعني في من اوله لاخره هو محور
الحديث اماكن عده ما ضربها لبن جانب
الاوكراني صفرات الانذار يعني منذ سبع
دقائق عقبه نهايه الهدنه التي انتهت ليله
الامس عند منتصف الليله بدات ضربات
الروسيه وانتشرت الاخبار كالنار في الهشيم
حول طبعا خارقه لا حول همم الزبورغي
المدينه الرئيسيه التي تقع تحت يعني
للحديث نعم عبد الجواد للحديث عن الميدان
عن المعارك همم سننتقل الى الزميره
الاخبار رائد كيف هو سير المعارك هناك
خصوصا اننا نتحدث ان محور دونياسك اليوم
والاساس والطاقي على كل الاخبار الصوره
معك تفضل
الانفجارات واصوات القصف العنيف من
المدفعيه ومن راجمات الصواريخ على طوال
اليوم بالفعل هناك احداث كثيره شملها هذا
اليوم ونبدا من استهداف الجيش الاخراني
لمحطات الطاقه
اعترضت صواريخ الدفاعات الجويه همم
الروسيه اعترضت صاروخ توشكا او ايضا
بالفعل اصفر والقذف الاوكراني عن قتيلين
واصابات وما زال منهم تحت الانقراض حتى
الان بينما نفذ كما اسلف في ال- اا القوات
الروسيه المقاتلات الروسيه كما اعلن
الدفاع الروسي وان المقاتلات الروسيه
الاستعداد همم
نقاط المعارك في العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا بشكل استراتيجي وكانت النتيجه
قصفت المقاتلات الاوكرانيه بصواريخ موقع
عام اوكرانيين كان يتركز بهذا بهذان
الموقع يعني
وتوكرانيه اعداد كبيره احدهما كان فيه 600
مقاتل والثالثه 400 مقاتل اسفلت هذه
العمليه حسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عن 600
كما ان هناك من ما زالوا تحت الانفاق حتى
الان غير يعني الاصابات
من القوات الشيشانيه اضافه الى الجنود
الذين
باسيطره على المدينه المتاخمه والبلده
المتاخمه وهي سردار في الناحيه الشماليه
همم بالفعل تمت امس السيطره على همم نقطه
هامه وهي
على اطراف الشماليه همم والمعارك العنيفه
قتال في سيلدار من اجل السيطره الكامله
على بلده سيلدار
وايه من تطوير الكامل والتقدم نحو بارك
متاكد الدفاع الاوكرانيه نفسها تقول بان
الاوضاع صعبه على الجنود هناك الجنود
الاوكرانيه
والجيش الروسي يؤكد انه خلال فتره ان لم
تكن قريبه فانه حتما سين ايه او سيحسن
معركه للسيطره على المدينه هي التي ستفتح
الى المدن الكبرى كرامه
بالفعل المعارك المحترمه في الشرق
الاوكراني بشكل عام وهمم يعني بنيت هي
المحور الاساسي شكرا لكم مراسله العربيه
عبر جواد رشد من موسكو ورعد الاخضر طبعا
من دنياك شكرا لكم على هذه الرسائل